thank you Hannah and welcome to this
event uh at Intelligence Squared with
Martin puckner uh part Martin is the
Byron and Anita Nguyen uh professor of
English and comparative literature at
Harvard University and the author of a
large number of books on literature
cultural history and philosophy amongst
which uh I wouldn't just mention a few
such as 2017's the written world the
power of stories to shape people history
and civilizations and 2020s uh the
language of Thieves about a secret code
language targeted by the Nazis for
elimination but we're here tonight to
discuss his most recent volume which as
Hannah mentioned is culture a new world
history which is now out from Norton in
the U.S and from Ithaca here in the UK
I'm going to start the conversation with
Martin in just a second but there are a
few
um housekeeping details which I thought
I would share with you before we begin
so tonight nights event is going to run
for about an hour and for the first 45
minutes or so Martin and I are going to
be having a conversation about the book
and the issues that it raised and then
I'm going to be taking your questions
um you can start asking them at any time
by clicking on the ask question button
under the screen and typing in your
question if you want your name to be
mentioned when asking the question uh
then type it into the box and press send
and as Hannah said please do tweet at us
during the course of the event the event
and and afterwards using the hashcare
iq2
so uh Martin uh thank you so much for uh
joining us and for doing this event this
evening I'm gonna start uh by uh just
getting a sense of how you embarked on
this it absolutely immense undertaking
and it is a book of enormous scope uh
chronologically geographically and
thematically so it moves uh from ancient
Egypt in the beginning to to K-pop in
the end from Mughal India uh to Medieval
Germany taking in poetry and and
sculpture and anthropology and prayer
and ritual and all sorts of things along
the way so what prompted you uh to
undertake this and and how did you go
about starting to think about such uh an
utterly vast topic yes thank you Edward
um I it started a couple of years ago
um in in a context where people
especially who are in the humanities in
Academia spend a lot of time we spend a
lot of time ringing our hands about
declining enrollments and I think people
generally in arts and culture people
don't care about Arts anymore what's
wrong what's going on and you know I
spend a good deal of time bemoting all
of these things as well but then at some
point I kind of paused and realized that
I had actually never really asked myself
some of these fundamental questions
about culture such as why do we engage
in this sort of mean
uh a non-utilitarian activity how does
culture actually work how did it proceed
what are the big arcs what are the big
themes of this human endeavor and so you
know then the pandemic hit and I you
know was stuck at home and I thought
well I have nothing better to do why
don't I do it now so I sort of dug in
and tried to go as Broad and wide Edward
as you said uh uh you know I I ended up
doing in order to sort of distill some
of these important moments turning
points sort of moments that sort of
illustrate to me how culture really
works and and I wanted to do that you
know not in a big survey but to sort of
Select these compelling case studies
about 15 and then tell them in a kind of
narrative and sort of interesting
immersive way hoping that out of you
know the sequence of the amount of these
different sort of case studies that that
bigger picture that I wanted to sketch
would somehow emerge
great thank you and and yeah I'd say
it's you know uh part of you know that
one of the solutions or one of the
potential solutions to declining
um admissions or enrollment uh it is
bringing the joy back and I think this
is one of the things that the book does
very well is just is bring the bring the
joy back and also in an age of of hyper
specialization where that you know that
the tendency is to focus on on quite
small things to think about these really
big questions about what is culture and
um you know why should we We preserve it
you said
um something in there which I want to to
come back to and press you a little
further on so one of the ways in which
the books is structured
um is by focusing on on moments of of
transmission
um and you know what I think you call
special places places and institutions
of meaning making so places where
culture is stored
um and and reproduced and and so on so
forth can can you tell us a little bit
about why we might choose to look at
culture in that way as opposed to
looking you know at moments of creation
or something like that yeah yeah fair
enough no and it's uh at first I didn't
quite know what to emphasize and so I I
really looked all over the place trying
to think about different case studies
what emerged as as a sort of through
line and transmission as you say was one
and in a way going back to the basics
the the very Purpose By Now fact that
culture is not transmitted automatically
you know unlike our genes that transmit
our human genome to the Next Generation
when it comes to culture cultural
knowledge we have to devise external
storage media and ways of making sure
that cultural knowledge gets transmitted
to the Next Generation and and because
otherwise it's lost and it so much is
lost all the time so for me storage and
transmission became crucial into you
know one place where I started is with
cave art and the Chauvet cave in
particular and in part because these
cave paintings are so amazing and you
know 30 40 000 years old produced over a
long period of time but above all I
started to think of these caves as sort
of one of the first storage places where
culture and cultural knowledge was
stored and transmitted to the Next
Generation and then of course there are
others libraries and universities and
and the internet and other technologies
that fulfill that function but caves and
temples and theaters and and other such
institutions and places in storage
Technologies
became Central
yeah and I think you know part of the
experience of a lot of uh Beauty and and
artistic beauty is no different than any
other is a sense of ephemerality the
sense that this extraordinary thing that
you're holding on to
um might simply simply disappear
um I I wonder
um whether also uh you know looking at
moments of transmission does something
to solve part of the part of the problem
of what we do with with historical works
of art right um in that uh you know you
and I both as as literature professors
you know know that we are are often
caught in a Enigma between trying to
discern authorial purpose what did the
creator of this work mean which is often
something that you can never quite get
to and never be quite certain about on
the one hand
uh and on the other hand uh throwing it
you know
widely wildly open to kind of reader
reception what did people take this to
me uh which you know to a certain extent
almost uh suggests that the work has no
uh you know that there's no
responsibility to the work of art so I
wonder whether you know choosing moments
of transition was a kind of Halfway
House in some way yeah yeah it's a very
interesting way of putting it I think
you're right
um uh you know I do have some moments of
creation you know for example the
Egyptian sculpture tutmose who creates
this extraordinary sculpture of Queen
Nefertiti and so I I you know I dwell on
that and that is sort of one of the
early chapters uh but then even more
fascinating to me is the fact that that
whole episode in in Egyptian history
which was so radical because Queen
Nefertiti invented a new God you know
left thieves started a new cities start
you know invented a new Aesthetics of
representation how that episode was
deliberately erased from history by
subsequent uh dynasties
perhaps because it was too startling and
too revolutionary and how it was then
rediscovered and reinterpreted and and
and so these moments of broken
transmission where something is lost
where something gets interrupted and
then it's rediscovered uh after a break
that those became to to my mind not uh
exceptions but really the rule and it's
very rare to find a genuinely continuous
cultural tradition there are always
these interruptions and breaks and so
that became a a special Dynamic that
that really stood out for me and so I
think I tried to find as many episodes
that look at that Dynamic from different
perspectives another one is a pillar by
the Indian king Ashoka a pillar he had
inscribed in order to present a kind of
Buddhist idea of Buddhist kingship that
was very important to him it become very
important to him and he erected these
massive Stone pillars in order to
propagate this new belief and also to
speak both to the Future and if you hope
to export Buddhism uh uh uh abroad
after a while the pillar became
illegible but then that didn't stop
people from going to it interpreting it
trying to understand why is this massive
pillar there subsequent rulers find it
transported to Delhi then finally it's
rediscovered and reinterpreted so so
those are these those are stories that
that that I I emphasized I think
precisely because of what you mentioned
Edward namely that it's it's of course
fascinating to think about these moments
of creation but the reason why we humans
create cultural products which are not
there for for our survival it's because
of this kind of collective
intergenerational process of meaning
making that's never complete it's never
at an end that's that's ongoing but
apparently really crucial to us because
we do it wherever we live and so it
seemed to me it's to gather that Dynamic
these stories of transmission and
rediscovery were were more important or
at least as important as just
celebrating the originality of artists
yeah wonderful and I
one of the things that I found and you
know most fascinating in the book is is
the part that you um talk about the part
that you see that error and
misunderstanding playing
um in in the transmission of culture so
whether or not there are breaks in
transmission you know um uh even if even
if you're successful in keeping
something
uh in uh you know in a kind of locked
box uh the context in which it was
originally understood
um disappear or they degrade and
suddenly it doesn't mean the same to the
person who opens the box so that old
kind of new critical fantasy of um the
well-wrought earn in which you can put
poetry and you seal it up and it comes
out fresh as a daisy 400 years later is
of course a fantasy because it doesn't
doesn't mean the same to to everyone but
I um so just to quote from the book
um you write that that errors are the
way in which a culture experiments
allowing new generations to project
their own concerns onto the past and to
inject urgency into its continuation
um I wonder if you could start by giving
us a few examples of this kind of
creative misinterpretation that you're
thinking if you've already given us one
uh with with a shocker and um and it's
pillow but if you can say a little bit
more about that and then you know we can
talk perhaps a little about you know
what we can do with that idea yeah yeah
so as you say errors become crucial and
it's odd because you know as a teacher
and research researcher I try to get
things right and in the book I try to
put things in their original context so
help myself and read us understand where
these things come from but at the same
time this theme of Errors really stood
out and and it seems to me in the end
efforts to minimize errors and
misunderstandings are probably misguided
because they are just they can be so
generative and have been so I just
mentioned Ashoka where people wants the
inscription became illegible
nevertheless continued oral stories
about who might have erected this pillar
and what what it might mean and
travelers come and encounter it and and
their Legends or Legends of various
kinds and uh you know we now know that
they are not technically true but there
are these pillars are almost like
magnets that that attract cultural
production so to speak stories
interpretations and that perhaps is more
important than than getting it right
another example is this so you mentioned
locked boxes I I actually became
obsessed with sort of time capsules
because the Chauvet cave with which I
start you know gets sealed up and then
doesn't get open for about 30 000 years
and it is sort of like a time capsule
another time capsule is Pompeii often
these get these are moments of
Destruction that paradoxically also
preserve a moment of culture and that
was true with the eruption of the
volcano in Pompeii in in 1879 one of the
things that was that we know because of
thanks to the volcano is that there was
this stat this Indian statue or South
Asian statue that was found in Pompeii
and it you know you can can retrace the
story of how how it probably got there
and it has a lot to say about trade
between the Roman Empire and and Asia
but it but it's also clear that that
that that's a small statue of of a
female goddess probably was part of a
history of misunderstanding it's very
likely that the Roman owner of that
statue probably thought she was a
version of of Venus or the Greek
Aphrodite which is not technically true
but that's just part of that
history of of interpretation and and
making something that's foreign from the
past your own understanding it with your
own cultural Horizon uh uh and and
that's most likely what what happened to
the Statue as well and you know there
are many other examples of that
yeah and it's uh you're absolutely right
there's so many examples fantastic
examples of this in the book in the ways
in which for instance the um that the uh
the bust of Nefertiti that you you begin
with becomes this provocative thing for
uh for Freud and Thomas Mann and and so
on so forth despite the fact that
in many ways their historical
understanding of these objects uh would
now probably not be you know
understandings that would be uh
particularly respected by modern
archaeologists and ancient historians
you know the revision and yet how
productive it was for them to to think
um through and with these objects was
important I mean I wonder again how how
you approach this as as a teacher
um in a sense that as you said at the
beginning you know we are um uh
to a certain extent in our role trying
to uh
if not set limits upon interpretation I
suppose
ensure that the interpretation is you
know is not
um
simply kind of imposed upon the work
that it that it's sensitive to the
historical conditions within which it
was created and yet recognizing the kind
of generativity of error I mean how do
we find a balance between uh
understanding the how the you know what
the object was originally made for and
um and allowing ourselves the freedom to
to reinterpret it yeah yeah but it's an
interesting dilemma the way I would
approach it is to say that I want to you
know when I teach but you know also when
I write I want to put students and
readers in a position where they learn
things where they have cultural
knowledge about this moment or about a
work that seems relevant and important
to know
that seems more important than sort of
imposing an interpretation I so because
teaching students and readers cultural
facts forces putting things in context I
think puts them in a position where they
can come up with uh with an
interpretation that is grounded in
knowledge rather than some you know
something random and I would say you
know in the defense of Freud and Thomas
Mann who then after the statute gets
rediscovered were find themselves super
intrigued that there there is this
moment in Egyptian history that
apparently we witness because of that
Discovery sort of the birth of
monotheism or sort of a Proto form of
monotheism and well you're absolutely
right Edward that you know some of the
spin that Freud puts puts on this you
know where he thinks that Moses was an
Egyptian uh uh and and perhaps tomasman
you know is speculative but I would
actually say that that these artists
um
in thinking about this cultural moment
and writing either a kind of you know
Treatise in in the case of Freud or a a
very long novel in the case of Thomas
man contributed to
um thinking about this episode in in
history and I think they're actually
current Scholars of
egyptology who
who are quite
cognizant of that reception history and
who use it and who interpret it in in
sort of similar ways actually so yes
these were you know not Scholars but
their response to this fascinating
moment in history uh I think it was a
serious one
um and it's still taken seriously so
it's so I think in the end it's not I'm
I'm not trying to hit readers over the
head with interpretations nor do I do
that with students but I think putting
people in a position where they can form
their own judgment based on some
knowledge I think that's sort of the
goal
um and I think it's you know it's
interesting how often in the history of
culture that what have um seemed perhaps
at first to be errors of interpretation
have later been seen to be kind of
intuitions of a deeper structure I mean
I think the number of times when
presumably people were crying cultural
barbarianism saying you know this is you
know this is the wrong way to see this
and when actually you know uh uh it
turned out later that you know there's a
there's a wider agreement with that so
I'm gonna move the conversation on uh
now a little bit to address uh the the
question that I suppose is is you being
used to structure uh this conversation
this event and which uh to a certain
extent looms over uh the book and looms
over the question of of cultural uh you
know cultural artifacts more generally
in nowadays this question of who owns
culture so they're in the background I
mean I think you know there's one way to
read this book
um which is is just as a sort of vast
um soaring flight over the history of
culture but another way to to read it is
is thinking about these questions of um
cultural appropriation and and cancel
culture and and so on so forth that have
been such a live part of
uh cultural conversations you know
recently so I I wonder if you could say
a little bit about the the threat to the
ways in which culture
um functions has historically functioned
that that are posed by or the danger
that's posed by some of these these
current conversations that we're having
yeah yeah you're absolutely right the
questions of cultural appropriation in
terms of culture and so on and so forth
were on my mind as I was writing this
book because this is you know if you
Google culture these days uh you know
most likely some of these terms will
will pop up and so I think it shows
among other things that we are at a
moment where we fight a lot about
culture
um and it's true that sometimes I feel
like oh I wish we were fighting less but
on the other hand uh I think it there's
something good about it in that people
care uh to care about culture uh this is
why we fight about something we care so
so here too I think it's in a way I
didn't just want to come down on some
position
in these contemporary debates but to
take a step back and to sort of gain an
understanding of how culture works how
is it transmitted how do moments of
creativity emerge what have happens at
these moments of cultural borrowing in
order to again inform a little bit the
debate perhaps in similar terms from
what we just talked about putting
readers in a position where they now
have a lot of sort of perhaps
interestingly selected historical
episodes that they can use in order to
think themselves about you know what are
the limits of cultural appropriation who
owns what what is legitimate what is not
legitimate so you know in the book I
didn't want to say okay this is good
this is bad this is okay
but I wanted to provide a lot of
materials
material with which to think about these
issues
and so but you know since you want to
push me to take some positions and
that's fair enough and because I do
think that there are some implications
perhaps
um and you know maybe to select one I
think also cultural appropriation is
used in so many different contexts
um and so I don't really use it in the
book because of it but let's select one
context and that's the you know the
whole debate about restitution of
objects from museums from the Elgin
marbles to statues from Benin and so on
and so forth and I I recognize there in
the in this particular context that for
example arguments of cultural ownership
can be quite powerful you know to say
yes Lord Elgin had some kind of contract
with that allowed him to take some
something back to uh to England but it
was a little bit murky in any case you
know this was a treaty between two
empires the British Empire the Ottoman
Empire but they're you know their their
questions that came can be asked the
same about the sotd statue that we
talked about earlier excavated by
oppression Expedition they were allowed
to take certain objects home how they
ended up with the Statue of Nefertiti
there are some questions about that
um and then they're more crasser
examples like in the case of Benin where
objects were taken just under so clearly
exploitative conditions uh of extreme
violence and disrespect
um and ended up in museums in you know
in London in Berlin and New York and
other places so I so I am of course I
mean I don't approve of such a theft
especially these extreme cases uh I also
understand that
to say you know this this comes from our
culture you took it under dubious
circumstances please return it can be a
powerful argument but perhaps one way of
articulating one place in which I ended
up uh in this whole question of
ownership is to say the goal of the
restitution
debate shouldn't be that everything just
goes back from where it came because I
think that would leave everyone
culturally impoverished because I do
believe in that sort of one takeaway
point from this whole history is that
cultural borrowing is just the single
most important driver of cultural
development so to apply if I were to
apply this to the restitution debate I
think I would say something it may be
not be very practical but to say the
goal is not just to return everything
but to say you know let's return Benin
statues as museums have
began to do but let's send something
else with them and let's come to an
agreement about how we can maybe borrow
some of these statues back and how they
can continue to circulate in a better
form to the one that under you know the
conditions under which they were taken
because I do believe that the goal
should be more circulation though
perhaps better circulation than less
circulation and I do sometimes worry
that getting too stuck on the language
of ownership erects barriers that in the
end are not helpful to anyone
yeah I agree with you that part of the
problem here might be
um you know the the tendency to fall
back on on metaphors of ownership which
is a you know a very um uh
uh vague concept which can range you
know across all sorts of different
things I I entirely also agree with you
on the need to um
to retain circulation and in fact I I
have also had a pet theory that instead
of you know sending back eldrin Marbles
and Benin bronzers that the government
should be forced to give them the
equivalent number of Turners and first
folios exactly uh you know um and so if
there's anyone on on here listening who
has the power to make that happen
um
but that is an option or happy although
it's entirely possible that the Greeks
don't want a bunch of Turners
um but anyway uh yeah so I think um I
think you're right that there is part of
the problem here is about the the
tendency to reach reflexively towards a
notion of ownership uh which can apply
to some things and um you know doesn't
apply very well to others so again in a
part of uh the cultural appropriation
debate is perhaps Complicated by
um distinction between objects and ideas
so you know thinking as a kind of limit
experiment
um on the one hand presumably you know
you're not telling people to go into the
National Gallery and take a Rembrandt
Off the Wall uh or or to to go into
bookstores and steal your book so you
know there's a way of owning you know
owning a kind of um a cultural object
but on the other hand uh there's clearly
you know reductio out of certain on the
other side which um you know saying
because the you know Arabs invented love
poetry which transmitted through the
Troubadours that no one should be
allowed to you know they should have a
kind of uh demand origin control on on
love poetry and no one should be able to
write it except them so there's clearly
um to a certain extent absurdities on on
on both both ends so my question is to
you about where we where does
where does um you know where do we draw
the line where where do we cease to be
able to own a cultural object and start
to be able to own uh you know and and
start to have something that really
can't be uh laid claim to by any
particular group yeah you know I think
you're so right once you move Beyond
objects I think it becomes very hard to
use the language and illid one and
ill-advised to use the language of
ownership I feel
um and so I I think actually the more I
think about it the more I really think
that it is impossible to draw the line
who should draw the line who should be
allowed you know sometimes when it comes
to immaterial cultural forms and ideas
you know it the language of cultural
appropriation is used I think to avoid
shallow uh you know or just sort of
super superficial uses of objects from
another culture or from the past and yes
I'm I'm not you know that's not great
I'm not for that but it I I find myself
harder and harder to press to say you
know this is this is good informed use
and this this isn't uh I do think it's
important to to generate a culture in
which
people want to learn more about
something even if they you know find it
on YouTube or somewhere
um where I think it's okay to say okay I
don't know very much about this but it
intrigues me so let's try to find out
more about it uh and so I'm all for
instilling that but I don't want to be
the professor who you know who says no
no no no no no you don't know enough
about this or you haven't earned the
right to you know uh to write love
poetry in this particular style I just
find it impossible to do
and you know and since you mentioned
copyrighted in my own book uh I'd say
you know the royalties we authors get
are so minuscule that people are
actually you know I don't want to
encourage staff but no one should feel
guilty with respect to me if they steal
a copy of my book or find it on the
internet in some form and the the thing
about copyright you know it's and there
it's not a book about copyright uh in
part because copyright is serious
copyright Productions have only been
around for like 130 140 years
but the the key idea about intellectual
copyright is that it expired and it
should be very short so that there are
some incentives for you know creative
artists and and and so on and so forth
to make a living and that's of course
important but that it expires because
the idea Beyond it is that you cannot
individually control this you know for
Generations because culture in the end
we all own culture together because it
is part of that you know I started to
think of it almost like a species
history of of humans
because we keep
doing this thing uh namely producing
cultural objects and and so I'm I'm
quite critical of
uh you know especially in the US a
copyright protections
keep getting increased and increasing
increase because of the Disney
corporations and the other big
corporations and that's I think another
way of you know coming back to what you
said earlier namely that our cultural
Moment In This Moment of capitalism
we've revert too quickly to to uh to
ownership and if you look at the history
of copyright Protections in the in the
last 50 years it's all been driven by
big Disney corporations and that alone I
think should give us pause when we use
ownership as as a kind of crucial way of
thinking about culture
yeah
so I'm gonna um come back to that and
ask a few more questions but I've got a
little reminder to myself here to um
tell the audience and to remind the
audience uh that you can ask your own
questions
um about a few more about 10 more
minutes of Martin I talking but we'd
love to hear your questions about the
book about these questions of culture
um so please do uh click on the ask
question button below your screen and
remember to press send when you finish
typing and uh and or please tweet at us
using the hashtag
iq2 so um yeah I I think you know one of
the
uh you know one of the difficulties here
um as you say with in a copyright case
it's important to allow the producer of
the you know the art object uh the
ability to it and living off that but
beyond that it's quite difficult to say
who can lay claim legitimate claim
um to to ownership of of this object uh
and on the other hand
um you know who
and similarly when when talking about
legitimate interpretations illegitimate
interpretations who can decide on these
legitimates you know on what constitutes
legitimate or an illegitimate
interpretation and to a certain extent
one one always has you know one ends up
falling back on on kind of assertions of
authority over an object and it's not
quite clear you know on what those
things are grounded right but uh I I
wonder if
um you know you uh had any you know if
there were feelings of exception uh you
know even if ownership ownership of
culture
um uh is not a useful way to think about
this uh whether this concept of cultural
appropriation you know we we can maybe
talk about some of the more uh you know
famous uh stories of this that have come
up in in the media whether there are
instances of this
um that you are consider you know you
attempted to consider as as exceptions
to to to your general way of thinking or
you know or confirmatory cases yeah so I
I think it's an interesting question so
in the end I mean there are lots of
moments of cultural contact or someone
using something that I think are bad or
Rife with violence and exploitation so
uh that that there's no question about I
I can come up to five mil in there are
many stories like that in the book you
know when the Spanish conquistadors come
to uh encounter the Aztecs and burn down
their cities and destroy their books uh
so that very few survive I mean they're
they're a lot of moments of of cultural
violence uh that that's inflicted here
that obviously are
um are terrible
um but when it comes especially to the
sort of more famous cases that go
through the media here and that get
labeled a cultural appropriation I think
my instinct is to say let's actually
look at how what people who use the
language of cultural appropriation are
trying to accomplish
by using this phrase and I think in most
cases I find that there are actually
better Alternatives I mean one famous
case about I don't know seven or eight
years ago that went through through the
media a lot in the US especially the
right-wing media where these students at
Oberlin College a very liberal arts
college that complained that the
cafeteria had sort of started an
international corner and was offering
Sushi and ban me sandwiches and then you
know Japanese and Vietnamese students
complained that the cafeteria that that
the cafeteria was practicing cultural
appropriation and so you know it's it's
very easy to make fun of this and a lot
of people did and I actually don't want
to make fun of it because if you
actually look at the student newspapers
you know where they where the where the
students were recorded as saying these
things and writing these op-eds what
they actually were trying to say is that
this was really terrible terrible Sushi
and the ban me sandwiches they used the
wrong bread they use ciabatta bread and
it was just really bad food that somehow
got put in that International quarter of
the cafeteria and so you know again I
I'm not for bad Sushi or these terrible
fake bani sandwiches that that that were
served so but this is a case where I
think the argument to make is not you
know cultural appropriation because then
you are in a situation where you say you
know should only Japanese students eat
sushi or only Japanese sushi chefs who
create sushis but it's sort of an
argument about equality and and how
serious is this engagement with this
cultural practice
um and where again where you want to
create a culture of
of Engagement and of of knowledge rather
than shallow and superficial uh uh one
but where in in my uh a case at least I
feel like the the much more effective
way has to do with quality and and to
look at you know what went wrong here
rather than to use this language of
default to this language of ownership
that I feel like is is actually not very
effective to
to explain what went wrong here and so I
think that's so this is sort of would be
my strategy not to say people who cry
cultural appropriation are are wrong but
that there may be a better way of
thinking about these cases
I don't know whether you have some
examples that come to your mind
um again I'm slightly conscious of
lapsing back on an economic metaphor
here but um you know perhaps one you
know one way to to think of it is of the
tendency of you know with Within
um
capitalist systems of monopolies to grow
unless you have mechanisms to insure
against that and to kind of Ensure the
recirculation of energy and if if what
one is uh or the recirculation of
capital in that sense and if what one is
looking for is the the recirculation you
know the circulation of culture the
sharing of culture
um that that to a certain extent
um
you know what one perhaps does have to
guard against is a situation in which
um
one a powerful actor with access to um
you know means of distribution
um far in excess of of you know everyone
else's
uh becomes the person who is telling
everyone else what you know what what
their culture is so again you know one
example that I suppose
um I I used to think of about this is I
think there was a fury a few years ago
about um Beyonce and I apologize in
advance if they're only in a queen Bay
fans out there
um but uh Beyonce using henna in a music
video
uh or something like this and on the one
hand it you know just seems a little
silly
um
um that you know you would would try and
prevent someone from celebrating whereas
she was you know she was not trying to
to mock or undermine the the idea of the
use of of henna hand decoration
um you know and and uh she was obviously
celebrating it's it's uh its cultural
power and its beauty on the other hand
you know part of my mind goes to
um you know the cultural use of uh henna
in in say India where it's this you know
it it's a ritual which binds together
the community community because it's
something that you know mothers and
mothers do with their daughters and
grandmothers do with their grandchildren
and then
um and you know the prospect of that uh
child some child who spends more time
with their iPhone than they do with
their grandparent um learning about and
coming to associate henna decorations
with Beyonce
um rather than with their grandmother
whilst certainly not something that I'd
want to you know
or I don't think um
that the you know kind of legislative
and capitalist language of cultural
appropriation necessarily fits it does
nevertheless conjure a sadness in me
um that that would be that would be how
they you know how they would know about
it so I suppose you know a question is
especially in this modern
um you know global hyper-connected
environment how we prevent
uh the world from being kind of flooded
with uh cheap ursats versions of you
know being flooded with bad ban me and
bad bad Sushi uh rather than uh having
access to goodbye me and you know good
sushi and making sure that
um you know the the Traditions which lie
at the heart of of making that
um you know of producing that with with
kind of love and knowledge aren't
Stamped Out by things that simply have a
greater kind of a greater ability to
produce quickly and cheaply and and
circulate more more yeah yeah yeah no no
I I hear that uh I mean uh
it I I don't think we'll be able to stop
the you know circulate circulation of
lot I mean we live in an age of
circulation
um and it I think my instinct always is
to say you know we can't prevent that
anyway
but how can we use it and who knows what
the effects of people
learning from be from Beyonce about this
particular cultural practice ultimately
are you know you I since we're now
talking about the you know the the very
end of the book in a sense in these
cases internet uh this is why I end with
K-pop
because K-pop sort of came of age of
course with the internet uh and I I
mentioned that anecdote where you know
I'm too old to have grown up with uh
K-pop I think you're too
um but my kids are obsessed with it but
um
and so I you know I don't have kids but
lots of you know friends do and my
nephew was and kids are friends and so I
mentioned this anecdote I was actually
staying with a friend in Norway and his
his kid was I think 11 at the time you
know I show up for breakfast and the the
kid is already up and has set his alarm
at you know 11 12 year olds don't want
to get up early for school and he's been
up and studying Korean with a textbook
by himself because he wants he's been
fascinated by Korea because of his K-pop
idols and so yes you can you know you
can say ah you know just watching K-Pop
videos what what what's worth that but
you never know what what some an
encounter a first encounter in a you
know let's shallow or mass media kind of
way what it leads to and again this is
makes me think that we I mean we can't
adjudicate it that way what we can do is
try to Foster as you put it so so nicely
a a culture of of Engagement of wanting
to learn really what where does this
come from rather than being content with
you know just sharing a video and so I
think the the strategy here is is again
it's not one of cultural ownership but
of cultural engagement valuing that
instilling that in people I think that's
the way to go
no I think you're absolutely right and I
think you know I'm talking about some
some limit cases and in fact you know I
think um you know K-pop and BTS with
which my kids are uh you know my
youngest son is obsessed it's a very
good example of both you know to a
certainly said BTS is built on you know
imitations or was it you know um
reformulations of the young Michael
Jackson itself it sounds very much like
that and and on the other hand you know
um the fact that BTS is globally
dominant suggests that you know
um good you know good cultural
Productions can win out even over you
know a capitalist you know capital
asymmetries or power asymmetries or
whatever so
um there's so many more things that we
could talk about but I've got lots of
audience questions so we need to move on
to to those now and as I say we've got
quite a few of them so
um I'm going to try and keep Mars into
reasonably short answers so we can uh
can get through uh many of them let's
start with um
uh with for instance one um from from
Kenny uh who was asked about the role of
women uh in cultural transmission so as
the as the role of women being
overlooked do you think in in cultural
in the the creation and transmission of
culture yeah it's a great question and
yes certainly the you know traditionally
the way the history of culture has been
told uh yes in so many spheres has
tended to overlock women which is why I
try to make a point of not doing that
starting with Nefertiti and there are
the the Queen of Sheba The Kebra attacks
that Edward you has all you have also
written about a fascinating Ethiopian
story of the Queen of Sheba and as a
kind of foundational figure for this
solomonic dynasty and how that text
circulates to uh to other you know all
the way to to George Eliot and I end
with the future Library Katie Patterson
uh and Margaret Edward uh that that
project about you know writers
sealing their stories for a hundred
years so that they will be released in a
you know in the future none of us will
be around to read them so I think that I
think that's
you know that was important to me not
just to retell the old story uh
um and focusing on the work uh or you
know paying continual attention to the
role of women was one important thing
the other was to tell not a western
story but a global story
yeah wonderful I understand there's so
many wonderful moments in the in the
book with talking about um hildegarden
Von Bingham which
um you see uh at the tip of the iceberg
of of female contribution to culture
which is often hidden in part because
you know of lack of access to literacy
and things like that so you know the
idea of the old wives tale which is
written off as unimportant book which
Lies Beneath you know um you know much
of of what we do have there survived so
um to take another
um uh another great question how do you
think the advanced um how do you think
Advanced AI will impact culture and
creativity I'm sure you're having the
same conversations at every dinner table
that I am about chat GPT and and what
this means and is it any good at writing
poetry and so on so forth so yeah no I
think about it constantly but to my
embarrassment I have to say I I changed
my mind about it about every five
minutes and here are the two positions
I'm constantly going back and forth
between on the one hand you know as I
mentioned I feel like this history is
sort of a species history of humans the
producers of culture uh and so I think
oh chatgpt it's so interesting because
it really emphasizes what's so human
about us how we create these you know go
through this meaning making process
AI doesn't try to make meaning of the
world try to understand our place within
it and create these special texts and
objects and environments and practices
to do so so somehow the story I told of
culture and of humans as a cultural
producing species is exactly captures
what's unique about us humans rather
than AI so that's you know and and I I
get a warm fuzzy feeling when I when I
tell myself that that when I make that
argument to myself and maybe to some of
my friends but then you know a second
later I uh and here we come back to the
theme of borrowing if there is one
takeaway Point uh from this book is that
originality is totally overvalued you
can look at any object or any traditions
and you see that it's made from bits and
pieces of other Traditions so that's
hence my emphasis on borrowing on late
Commerce on the circulation of culture
and that's in a sense exactly what chat
GP or the AI does it takes bits and
pieces and puts them back together and
this is what we humans have been doing
all along so suddenly it the humans look
like you know less good versions of chat
GDP or just different versions of GPT
and so that I haven't quite puzzled that
one out but those are the two positions
I always find myself oscillating between
on on several times a day
yeah it's a you know it's a fascinating
question but you know it can also be
these kinds of things these kinds of
challenges can be a catalyst for culture
in the way that you know the uh the the
Impressionists uh were responding in
some ways to to the need to do something
that a camera couldn't and so maybe you
know the next challenge is to find
something that chat GPT can't do
culturally uh or use chat GPT to do
something that we haven't done before
because it's you know in the end it's a
tool in the history of cultural making
it's a history of tools and so that's I
think in the end if I were if you hold a
gun to my head and said you have to come
up with one formulation it would be that
it's just another tool and we have to
learn to do it and if you know we will
do something maybe really interesting
with it
yeah I agree so interesting times ahead
um I'm going to move to another question
so this is another pretty pretty broad
one
um how important do you feel religion
has been in the in the transmission of
culture it it I'm glad this question
gets asked it is a broad one but you
know one of the problem
problems of using terms like culture or
literature or the Arts is that these
tend to be relatively recent inventions
and if you go back and this is why I
ended up with this also broad notion of
culture which I sort of Define
essentially as meaning making or meaning
seeking activity and if you go that
broad
um because otherwise you know you with
cave art is is that religion is that art
is it you know are these exhibitions is
this a gallery you know it's just it's
it's very clear that we it's very
dangerous to impose you bring these
terms to to the dis especially the
distant past but in the end that's what
they have to do to some extent so
it since I've just deliberately went
broad enough and vague enough not to
impose very recent sort of distinctions
about let's say art and and religion it
you you you cast a very night White net
and including religion and so starting
with Nefertiti the history of Buddhism
plays a big role we just mentioned
Ethiopian Christianity there there's a
chapter on on on the Golden Age of
Arabic letters in the store of a house
of wisdom in Baghdad and so absolutely I
think religion is part of you know even
Central to this history of uh of meaning
making and it often especially in the
more distant chapters it it's impossible
to disentangle art art from religion
um and so
um I so I think it's part and parcel of
it uh uh and I'll just leave the answer
that
great thank you um so um moving on to uh
another question this is to a certain
extent um I suppose a continuation of
some of the things that you were saying
and um and I'm going to kind of develop
the question a little so this is a
question from
um from Arthur who asked about the
theory of black Athena which argues that
the roots of Greek civilization lie in
Egypt and the near East um and again you
know if you think about I think you talk
a little bit about Plato Plato going to
Egypt to seek knowledge and and so on so
forth and that that idea that
um cultural transmission
has its roots I wonder if you could talk
a little bit about that and also
about the idea in the book that um
culture is often something that is
you know is sort of worryingly Elsewhere
and um and you feel the need to kind of
travel towards it yeah no I think that
black Athena a story is is really great
because it disrupts something that that
I'm also trying to disrupt maybe some
idea of culture of especially if Western
culture that goes like this that somehow
it imagines a culture as a relay race
and you know the Greeks have have the
Baton of culture and then they pass it
on to Rome and then I don't know Rome
passes it on to Europe and so on and so
forth and you realize just how much we
try to enlist the past and tell these
simplified stories of cultural
transmission and so the the story about
black Athena and the relationship
between Greece and in North Africa it
interrupts that uh this is why I have
this chapter in Ethiopia because to
interrupt that story that somehow
Saharan Africa doesn't have literature
scribal traditions
so so I think I think it's very
important to realize that certain ideas
of especially High culture that were
developed in you know in the UK and in
Europe especially in the 19th century uh
are just
really wrong and if you look at a
broader and truly global history of
circulation you you realize exactly how
important North Africa was for Greece
for example or the contact between the
way in which Ethiopia borrows from and
then develops further these ideas of
monotheism from from from uh from the
Middle East
how that in turn in the 20th century uh
has an Afterlife with the Rastafari
movement and so on and so forth so these
more complicated but also so much more
interesting stories and also I think
more accurate and here I will use the
term more correct and accurate stories
of of culture that completely
wrong-headed ideas of you know the
Western World you know often racist
conceptions of cultural history
completely ignored and left out and
really simplified uh in in a in a in a
misleading way
how culture has really circulated and
and transmitted and the story of India
and and and Rome is would be another
example so great question
yeah and I think you know um the entire
um
uh the the energy put into attempts to
to build kind of neat cultural
genealogies some kind of mono mono
causal cultural genealogies is is in
some ways an expression of the anxiety
uh that individual cultures don't
necessarily really exist that actually
when you look at the borders of them or
even look at the heart of them
um they're so uh you know so Blended and
so multi you know kind of multi-causal
but it's it's very difficult to say
um that something even
um you know exists at the heart of it uh
we're almost out of time I'm looking for
um a question to end with I'm afraid
this isn't a simple question it's one
that you've sort of
um
you sort of addressed before but I think
it's a good note to end on about this is
from Jess asking if you think that
objects of cultural significance should
be in so-called Universal museums or
return to the communities where they
were originated and so I suppose this is
a closing question about about place and
and culture and and globalism so yeah no
I mean it it it's it's hard to come up
with you know one rule to adjudicate all
cases and I think that you know I
mentioned Benin statues uh where it's
clear that these you know these cultures
in West Africa were so so much was taken
from them and that it's so clear that
they need cultural objects as well as
ideas and impacterial practices to
connect to their own past and to figure
out you know what which parts of it you
know are important and not important and
so on and so forth um so I I do think
that sometimes times demands for
restitution are very legitimate and not
just because and again maybe not even
primarily for uh ownership questions uh
but because it's very clear that these
communities really have a vital interest
and need of these objects
um so absolutely at the same time I also
think that it is important and should be
in the interest of all cultures to have
bits of their cultures circulate more
widely because it's a way of having
influence of often
ensuring a kind of cultural survival the
story of Buddhism I tell is one you know
where it or it originates in India then
sort of declines in India but Fortune it
was exported to China and it thrives in
China and then it sort of diminishes in
China and it gets transported to Japan
where it thrives and so on and so forth
and these are so as a culture I think in
some sense you want to be
taken up by others uh um though
hopefully in a non-exploitative and also
non-shallow way of course so I think
this is this is maybe the note to end on
that yeah I'm afraid it's it's a perfect
it's a perfect note to end on and it's
perfectly timed as well since we're out
of time so
um uh I think uh I'll draw it to the
close there just uh by thanking uh you
so so my thanks to Martin pukner uh and
to our audience uh and to Intelligence
Squared
thank you so much Edward
thank you so much Martin and Edward that
was such a rich and fascinating and
thought-provoking conversation it's
wonderful to hear you to move away from
the ideas of cultural ownership and
appropriation to a cultural transmission
and engagement and uh if you do want to
know more here is the book available in
all good bookshops now
so from all of us at Intelligence
Squared thank you for watching and we'll
see you again soon good night
thank you